The joe rogan experience.
Yeah.
Well,
you know,
it's a fucking sick,
John Man.
Yeah,
no,
I get it.
But honestly,
come you like,
I liked family tides.
I'm not even fucking around.
Like I liked family ties.
Uh,
but that's about d like two and a half men.
Ah,
I'll say this for two and a half men.
I've seen it on mute a few times on the plane and it looks like they're having a
good time.
Then maybe the best answer anyone has ever to their questions.
And then occasionally I'll hear like a Dick joke and I'm always like,
that's a pretty strong dick joke for the,
for,
for a sitcom at that time slot.
I only watched it once recently and I thought it was the most unbearable thing
I'd ever seen on television and I thought it was incredible that it's so
popular.
We were talking about it yesterday.
I,
I'm,
I was baffled by it.
I couldn't believe how bad the jokes were.
I was like,
this is just,
this is just an alien language,
right?
I'm watching it with my mouth open and I'm hearing the laugh track and I'm like,
this isn't even my language.
Like what the fuck?
If you don't watch your show with a laugh track for a while and then you do it,
you're like,
yeah,
I would like to watch it and have it all the laughs extracted like someone do it
through pro tools,
go in there,
extract all the labs and just have him say the the jokes and have no response
and see how fucking bizarre
I want him to do that.
Where every po you take the laughs out and then every punch line I just go Bam.
See like curb your enthusiasm has no laugh track.
You know?
And it's hilarious.
But if you did that with a show like two and a half men take out all the laughs.
Yeah.
And only have them act out the scene.
It's fucking preposterous.
But having said that,
cheers.
Had a laugh,
track sign photo,
the laugh track friends had a laugh track.
Hey,
there's nothing wrong with a laugh track.
What I'm saying is when something's really horrible.
Yeah.
And then you're just faking it.
And when,
if you could just listen to it without the laughter,
it would be so
that's like that movie that looks like,
uh,
the movie with them.
I always forget the guy's name,
the guy from who hosted the Oscars and he's handsome.
He wrestled rolling
steel,
steel robot boxers.
That looks good.
That is it.
I think it looks awesome.
It's like boxing match.
It's like a boxing the deck.
Rocky mixed the transformer.
Everyone looks like a real steal.
Yeah.
Rosio at first I thought it was a knock.
'Em sock.
'Em Mood.
It is.
And that's pretty much what it is.
Yeah.
I thought it looked good.
Just cause I liked that.
Just transformers.
Hugh Jackman shirtless in the real steel trailer at jam.
I want to see that bastard.
I'm a nerd.
You fucking ruined the Wolverine Character,
man.
I don't care what anybody says.
Wolverine supposed to be like five foot three and built like a,
I find those movies pitiful.
I find the odd,
the fact that they can only do superhero movies now,
just pitiful.
Like it's there.
It's,
I told someone,
it's like,
it's there for dumb people to be able to explain to other dumb people.
Like there's a dude and he got bit by a spider and he's half and half man.
And he wears a uniform.
So you're never confused about who's who.
And he's got a logo on the superman,
has a logo on the front and the back in case you get them.
You're telling me you don't like comic book movies,
man.
Uh,
I liked,
I'm such an old man.
I liked the Chris Reeve.
Superman.
Whoa.
And uh,
which other ones have I liked?
I didn't like x men.
I didn't like know,
like Spiderman
didn't like,
oh,
I'm watching the trailer for this,
this rock 'em sock.
'Em robots moving.
I like the Batman movies.
I like the new Batman.
I like the Tim Burton ones and I like the,
uh,
the,
what does names?
Yeah.
This,
by the way,
this premise of this film where there's robots and the people like where this
robot outfit and get in fights.
It's a fucking great idea,
man.
That's actually real robots.
Oh,
these are robots in,
they're controlling them remotely.
That's what it is.
No,
they're just,
they're just training robots idea.
Does it have avatar robot?
Yes.
We fucking awesome of Avatar robot fights.
To me,
it's no different than racing cars.
You know what you're racing cars,
you know,
you're not supposed to be moving that fast.
You're using a machine,
move that fast,
you know,
and you're bumping into each other and cutting and cutting each other off.
In one of those that was in,
uh,
it was in,
um,
the end of x men or the end of,
uh,
of,
of uh,
ironman wasn't,
that wasn't Jeff Daniels and like,
uh,
didn't,
didn't I liked that movie too.
Uh,
yeah.
All right,
man.
It was fun,
right?
Yeah.
He's a new Koni on it.
Looks Fun.
A lot of people are shitting on it online.
It looks pretty fucking bad ass to me.
And they're like saying that they owe that guy can't be cone and he's not built
enough.
He's not this.
No.
Nobody really looked like Arnold Schwarzenegger and I fucking 1500 BC.
Right.
That shit's unrealistic.
No carbs.
Yeah,
it was just all red meat back then.
He was on a strict diet in the,
in the,
in Paleolithic Times,
Paleo Diet,
Paleo.
That's what a lot of people are doing right now.
So that's true.
It's all the rage.
You didn't know that.
That's a good book.
Paleo diet is all like vegetables.
No grains,
no rice.
Oh yes,
that's good.
It's all things that are meat and vegetables.
You know,
things that people in the Paleolithic would've eaten right before agriculture,
before hot dogs and shit.
Um,
yeah,
those,
uh,
you think that that's,
I guess I'm,
I'm,
I'm out of touch with what the people want.
Yeah.
I,
uh,
I just a big fan of robots and,
and good CGI is you're a big fan of frogs now.
Doesn't it look like good CGI in a financial way of looking at this movie?
I think it's the most genius thing ever.
You're mixing like fighting like UFC,
mixing it like robots.
Like it was generated by a computer,
robots and fighting like the Pan,
a guy who had guys on,
on his luck and then the,
you know,
yeah,
I see that too.
I mean,
I don't know.
I think it's a good idea for kid,
for a kid movie.
I'm guessing that's what this is kind of like a teenager movie is good.
You mean a movie?
Cause that's their all for all for these goddamn teens.
Teens.
No,
I've said,
I told somebody that if the Godfather was released today,
Michael Corleone,
word a spandex suit,
she on it
and drive a fucking buy like a bat.
We'll be able to be like an Oldsmobile.
No via cannoli movie.
Giant Pinoli
sue the G on it.
Oh,
how funny would that be if somebody pitch that in a meeting?
I just think he's the best.
I still,
everybody loves him.
He's number one,
right?
It's different.
Yeah.
He puts it on.
He goes down,
he fucks up your nose.
You know who it is.
Everybody's got a costume.
Uh,
just a costume that retarded people can understand.
That's superman.
You just go,
oh yeah,
he's fucking,
I'm retarded.
That definitely superman.
What is your take on this fucking Spiderman thing that they're doing and
Broadway,
you know,
you know the whole story behind this,
the Spiderman play,
it's the biggest,
most expensive play they've ever produced by far on Broadway.
And apparently it's a fucking financial disaster
and,
and people are dying.
People get rid of their fucking backs and shit.
I was,
if there was another accident,
I was going to do a Twitter,
a tweet where I'm Spiderman himself came out and condemn the musical.
I was like,
look,
we've got to stop that as Spiderman.
Please give me a bad name.
That's funny.
Yeah,
no shit does the thing where this is the guy's a hero.
He wants to save people and it's fucking,
and it is more people have been injured then.
Yeah.
They've killed more people than the Green Goblin.
Am I right?
Am I right ladies?
And they,
they're flying around during this broadcast,
right then there during this,
uh,
this performance,
they fly around like they're on a,
where they've reopened it,
they're trying to just read,
they brought the original director back.
It's just a,
it's like,
hey,
you just want to say it.
I'm like,
Hey,
you guys know you don't have to do this.
You're going to stop.
Right.
That is where I wanted to like just maybe just stop.
It's hard though.
Once you commit to something,
it's pretty much over,
you know?
It's very difficult to quit something once you're rolling.
Admit that it's,
you know,
there's a,
the term is motivated reasoning where you just go,
oh,
no,
but we wanting the whole,
the whole reason you're saying is because you want it to be good.
You can also tell by people's Pitch,
oh yeah.